بالنسبة إلى رون كاثرين ، كانت السمنة عبارة عن
صراع مدى الحياة ، لقد
جربت العديد من الأنظمة الغذائية المختلفة
من هذه الطبيعة ،
وزدهرت أخيرًا ما يزيد قليلاً عن 350
رطلاً
، ولذلك اختار المعيار الذهبي في
جراحة إنقاص الوزن
، فقد سارت الجراحة نفسها
بشكل جيد  بعد ثلاث ساعات ، كانت
المشكلة الأولى في
ارتفاع معدل ضربات القلب ، حيث
كان ضغط الدم ينخفض ، وك
ن لوني يتغير ، و
ل الجراحون المشكلة بسرعة ، لكن كاثرين وا
هت أيضًا عدة نوبات من متلازمة الإغراق حي
رفض جسده الطعام وا
مغذيات التي كان يأ
لها.  من الأشياء
التي يحب الناس التحدث عنها كثيرًا
في الواقع ، لا يحدث أن الكثير من
لين يقول إنه يخبر المرضى أن يكونوا على دراية
بالمخاطر وليس فقط المضاعفات الجسدية ولكن النفسية
والمالية
التي تفقد الكثير من وزن هؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين
إذا لم يعد
أصدقاؤك أصدقاء لك بعد الآن ،
فهذا أمر مدمر للغاية عندما تكون في
وحدة العناية المركزة لفترة من
الوقت وأنت  لا يمكنني العودة إلى العمل أو
العبء الاقتصادي
الذي يقع على عاتق عائلتك إذا
كنت سأعاني من نفس المضاعفات
مرة
أخرى وعرفت أنني سأواصل العمل وأقوم بذلك
مرة أخرى في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا
سوزان هندريكس